ça va la santé là je sens que ça faiblit
un peu alors on va faire une interview
cercueil
[Musique]
voilà la fameuse sardines en boîte
beige
ça va alors je m'étonne
c'est la première fois lorsque je ne
suis pas superstitieux mais justement
c'est une façon de conjurer le sort un
jour le sort bien entendu alors comme ça
jean pierre vous êtes mort ouais
mais dites moi vous aviez passé un pacte
avec le diable pour durer aussi
longtemps oui oui uniquement pour
ennuyer mes camarades il disait il va
bien partir d'aujourd'hui la cbk t'as
pas un couvercle
même morts ils nous emmerdent encore
trop qui la ramène un huit mois mais
maintenant avec ce pacte avec le diable
n'avait pas peur de l'enfer non non non
mais j'ai fait zone rouge ouais oui
c'est vrai mais des flammes et s'est
donc je suis habitué je suis déçu par ma
famille parce qu'ils auraient pu choisir
mieux quand le cercueil est rien et
politiques avec avec ce que je leur ai
laissé ouais
vous êtes mort comment il est mort après
une vanne de dechavanne
saveur en bouche et les coronaires et
alors vous avez une attaque et voilà et
je suis parti je suis parti assez vite
c'est parti très très vite et puis je
suis arrivé là où vous voyez très bien
conservé layec la une la aux abandons
merde alors
ça s'appelle l'enfer
chaque place bien votre mort ça va ça se
passe bien je ne vais pas me plaindre ça
pour une mort c'est une mort assez assez
cool vrai je pensais que c'était plus
dur que ça la mort ben ça va alors ça va
je suis content ça a été douloureux pour
vos proches j'imagine oui sont beaucoup
plus en plus parce qu'on les voit ils
ont beaucoup pleuré mais vous savez
quand j'étais vivant j'ai raconté
l'histoire du médecin de caries oui que
tout le monde croyait que c'était un
faux médecin il a dit je vais vous
prouver venez au cimetière je vais
réanimer un mort alors elle a dit celui
ci ça pharma 10e non parce que il m'a
cassé les pieds pendant toute ma vie il
a essayé de réanimer 5 6 ou 10 personnes
et tout le monde a refusé que les morts
reviennent voilà de vienne sur terre
alors moi je vais rester là on est une
des légendes effectivement de votre
livre vous voulez quoi comme musique
pour votre enterrement royer de musique
que j'adore elle est de gainsbourg ça
s'appelle sous le soleil exactement à
très bien ce serait bien non bien sûr
chantée par anna karina tu vois la
coloration écouter
voilà
ça vous a touché les funérailles
nationales commentée par jean claude
narcy oui j'ai regretté la mort de six
trône que j'ai vu tout à l'heure tient
real reviendrait la caf est ensemble
je lui ai dit je regrette que ce soit
pas toi qui est fait mais fédéral
national mais jean-claude c'était bien
avec toutes ses décorations et bien
ouais y avait une note aussi qu'un tel
détachement militaire
c'est que les services publics a donné
aussi pour la gerbe à vous êtes je suis
au courant ils ont ils ont payé un petit
peu ils ont je suis au courant je
remercie énormément de service public
j'ai beaucoup donné au service plus
belle je sais c'est pour ça qu'à gerbe
aussi
alors maintenant que vous êtes mort est
ce que vous avez réussi votre vie ou pas
franchement j'ai réussi ma mort oui
c'est sûr elle a été parfaite en a
beaucoup parlé il ya eu une belle
cérémonie non j'ai réussi ma mort ma vie
bon bah j'ai dû faire des bêtises dans
ma vie
enfin j'ai tenu une couche que loin à 48
heures vous aimeriez qu'on dise quoi de
vous maintenant que vous êtes mort
l'important c'est ce qu'il ya dans la
boîte
et l'oraison funèbre de philippe risoli
vous l'avez aimée ben non non parce que
j'aurais préféré qu'ils lâchent en tas à
l'imparfait du subjonctif pour un
animateur bah oui c'est le seul
animateur qui envoie la mauricie
absolument
alors jean piat qui reste maintenant que
vous êtes mort chevron drucker et
lasseube rendre au caire ardisson ses
limites parce qu'il va pas bien ouais
j'ai vu la dernière fois il va pas bien
va falloir que ça à faire encore une
arrivée dans les jours qui viennent et
voilà justement que j'espérais retrouver
kiehl ao maintenant vous y êtes tout ce
que j'ai aimé parce que plus en avance
dans la vie plus ce que vous aimez ne
sont plus là hélas et je suis très
heureux d'être là parce que je les
retrouve tous et figurez-vous qu'il
m'attendait pas si tôt mais il
m'attendait
qu'est-ce que vous avez oublié de faire
avant de mourir d'éteindre la lumière ah
ouais vous souvenez de vos parents qui
vous disaient éteint la lumière ferment
le robinet ne laisse pas couler l'eau
pendant tout brosse les dents donc moi
j'ai oublié d'éteindre la lumière je
m'en excuse auprès de celles et ceux qui
ont pu le faire à ma place il aidait les
mêmes mort la mort correct est ce que
vous pensez qu'il y aura une rue à votre
nom à marseille oui oui oui bien sûr ah
c'est quand même la bonne des choses oui
j'ai pas arrêté de défendre l'om même
dans les situations les plus difficiles
j'ai pas arrêté de dire du bien de
marseille alors que tout le monde a pris
les clichés pastis sieste pétanque etc
dans le nord il y aura une avenue une
avenue elle sera juste à côté de
l'impasse laurent baffie
derrière la décharge dans une voie sans
issue et 65 est-ce que vous croyez qu'il
aura un modèle de ventilateurs à votre
nom oui oui oui levante issouf 38
oui c'est du bien un peu derrière nous
avait demandé à la famille rilsan quand
vous voyez plus que moi je vois votre
fille souvent ils sont contents ils ont
l'air content oui mais c'est pas ça
c'est pas ça un moteur de leur vie un
moteur de leur vie c'est les prières
pour celui qui vient de partir à
d'accord ils sont bien dans la famille à
votre avis faut-il rire de la mort jean
pierre bel qu'est ce qu'ont fait
d'autres là maintenant un message
pour presque tu veux essayer la taille
au dessus jambes parce que là je
dis c'était quoi votre dernier mot
c'est une question très très difficile
mon dernier mot c'était quand le type
est arrivé en fermant le couvercle il a
dit je peux et je dis ce dernier mot il
a rigolé c est pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de nos latitudes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou